listen I want to start with a sincere
congratulations on the movie
um I know this couldn't have been an
easy project to get made with the
financing and everything just want to
say congrats ah thank you thank you so
much thank you
um so I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning
um for all three of you if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before uh what is the first thing you
want them watching and why let's start
that way oh wow
uh besides the inspection which comes
out November 18th
um huh I guess the first thing I would
want them to watch is my documentary
peer kids it's about queer and trans
homeless youth in the Christopher Street
in the West Village and how they use
public space to find chosen family and
to overcome homelessness I made the
movie over five years I made it
literally with you know in my dorm room
with a camera that I purchased and my
own you know it's a little literally
made from the mud and now it's on PBS
and I want to film independent Spirit
award so I would I think if you want to
get to know me and where my heart is an
artist that's a really great way to
start right I'm gonna piggyback that if
you want to get to know me you need to
watch the inspection because I'm in the
season of champion elegance and it comes
out November 18th and I want you all to
be in the theater to see it so that
feels very pressing and special on my
heart right now so I would love to gift
whomever out there
no I think I think for me um to know me
like as an as an individual you gotta
watch Bring It On that's pretty much me
in real life you want to know who I am
like in my soul uh you have to watch the
documentary half the sky that we did uh
where we explored well my part of it
explored the educational disparities
between boys and girls in uh communist
Vietnam that is that's what's on my soul
that's that's what I that's kind of more
of who I am uh elegant I have an
individual question for you um what
you've obviously done a lot of shorts
before but this is your feature debut
um directorial debut what was it uh uh
what was it about this story that said I
want this to be my feature directorial
debut did you ever think it might be
something else
I was at a point well first of all I get
gotta give credit or credit to my life
partner Chester Al General Gordon I was
at a moment in film school where I had
uh I was going to choose between doing
uh the feature version of my short walk
for me or this film the inspection and
Chester was just on me and to be like
listen you need to tell a story that no
one else could tell except you
and what made it make sense is that you
know before I joined the Marine Corps my
mother kicked me out for being gay I
spent 10 years homeless during that from
16 to 25. during that time I thought I
was worthless I thought I had no value I
thought I didn't mean anything to anyone
because my mother told me so my whole
life and then I get to the Marine Corps
and I find out I'm valuable because I
can protect the person to my left and to
my right that that empowered me you know
I I didn't expect to find that
empowerment in that way in boot camp but
I did and I just feel like in this
moment we're living in where things are
so polarized between conservative and
liberal and Democrat Republican male
female black and white we need something
that can start a conversation between
both sides right rather than screaming
at one another what does it look like if
we focus on our shared humanity and that
human connection and this film is really
really centered on that I'm curious for
the two of you what was it like reading
the script for the first time and was
this one of these things where you're
three pages in and you're like oh I'm
doing this I think for me you know I
read the script and I was fortunate to
be able to hop on a zoom with Elegance
right after just to have a conversation
my team had sent it to me just like we
think you should meet This brilliant
soul and that's exactly what he was he
was a special energy and I'm always
looking to work with you know creatives
that are just doing special and unique
work
um and that that's where he was at in
his life and we really just got to have
a conversation about what does it mean
to be an artist what does it mean to be
a black queer artist
and how we want to use our voices and
our truths and our pain to to be
something bigger for other people to be
that Beacon of representation or
something that's tangible for someone
out there to go I'm gonna be okay I can
also do this my dreams are valid I am
worthy I am more than enough so being
able to have that conversation
immediately after reading the script was
kind of you know it was it just felt
like I would you know be so blessed to
be on that Journey with him
and when I when I got the script it was
to produce and and to act and I got the
producer part I got where I could be
impactful as a producer because it's a
it's a the script is a winner you read
things you're like sometimes you're like
I'm gonna this one's gonna require
surgery and like and like a whole like
slew of writers and a lot of like a lot
of stuff
um but this it was like as as is was was
beautiful it was a winner as a producer
I'm like cha-ching uh but I'm like now
who would I be in this they're like the
mother I'm like ah don't see it
um but Elegance had a confidence in me
that I've never had in myself or my
ability and he saw that I something in
me that that told him that I could pull
this off
and because he had so much confidence I
had to figure it out on my you know I
had to find it within myself but it
started with the words
um and a lot of times the words are just
not there and from literally page one
you're
you're Blown Away
um so yeah but it was it was a winner
from page one there is a very powerful
scene in this movie
um uh in the third act in a hallway and
I know
um it must have been a challenging day
on set to film that scene
um I don't know how much you want to say
about it because I'm trying to be
guarded with spoilers uh but can you
sort of talk about filming that sequence
because it's so emotional and it's raw
and it feels so honest right I want to
speak about it yeah I think what it is
is you know this is a very unique
filming experience for for I think all
of us gab's expressing she had to go to
a place and dig from something that felt
foreign you know and I was you know
making myself available for Elegance
because this is real pain and this is a
real real life events and things that
were said to him so my responsibility
was just to show up for him that day
specifically in the hallway because as
he has said a lot of the things that you
know gab was saying were said to him so
I knew that we would just it needed to
be a safe environment and we needed to
be open and we needed to be able to to
go through that healing in real time
together on that day
um and I'm very proud of that scene I'm
very proud of how gab showed up
um because we had to hold each other
down in a real way it was it was hard
not to want to break down in tears the
whole time because you Jeremy is is
struggling with just the idea of what
this means for for French and what this
meant to Elegance but I knew that by by
us by us going through it it meant that
he went through it and what that means
is he could then leave that peace in
that hallway and he didn't have to carry
you know the weight of that heaviness
you know much longer
my last thing real quick aliens I I read
that you uh uh the Kate Blanchett test
for Jeremy which I found very funny can
you explain what that test means sure
the Kate planchette test is essentially
if you watch a Kate Blanchette movie I
feel like there's always a scene where
it's just her emoting to camera there's
nobody no other actors and through her
emotions you can track what she's been
through and get a sense of where she's
going right can an actor just Captivate
right and Jeremy passes that test in
flying colors the most expressive eyes
the most sensitive Soul you're like my
favorite actor dude
thank you you're welcome
but yeah that's the Kate Blanchette test
on that note I mean a sincere sincerely
again congratulations on the movie and
um I hope you guys have a good round of
speed dating today oh thank you so much
have a great day